brazil is in the thick of covid turmoil
and those who have lost loved ones are
risking their own lives to protest
their anger in amazon's biggest city
manaus
hospitals are close to collapse with
medical supplies dwindling
and intensive care units nearing
capacity and now
there's a shortage of oxygen
my grandmother died today because of
lack of oxygen there were 21 patients in
the cti
split in equal groups and my grandmother
84 years of age
couldn't survive she needed 15 liters
she didn't have enough
hospitals are preparing to airlift
patients to other states where beds are
available
the strain on the system this time
thought to be exacerbated by the new
brazilian variant
we are at the limit of our icu capacity
and the capacity of our medical clinics
we have exceeded all international
records in these areas
we are running low on oxygen supplies
and this is a big problem
for us the state's health care system
struggled during the first wave of the
pandemic
doctors stress the only way out this
time is a vaccine
which brazil is yet to roll out despite
the intensifying picture
the country's president continues to
downplay risks of the disease
and the effectiveness of the vaccine
the vaccine is voluntary nobody will be
forced to take it
if you don't want it don't take it it's
your right
we have no proof that the vaccine is a
cure that does no harm
or that will have no side effects as a
public leader i wouldn't force you to
take this medicine
who is to say this on something that is
not scientifically proven
if you take it today we are going to
assume it works
the state has made an urgent call for
help only too aware with every passing
hour
this shortfall in oxygen supply
continues to cost lives
ash naharing sky news